behind the faces of those who have
escaped mariopol is the trauma of 45
days in hell
this is the story of The Borax one
couple one experience let's go inside
and have a chat okay
but replicated over and over we'll find
some some seats
the First theme people saw and we bought
out of the hospital your
dead bodies in the streets it was
horrible people
different people of different ages
sometimes whole families with children
because there was the shell or the bomb
and they just got in their own place and
they were killed it was horrible
mariopol has been home for Tatiana and
Valerie for almost their whole lives
our apartment was on the 11th floor so
the bomb actually got into the apartment
above us into the 12th and that
apartment just
destroyed itself and our apartment so
all our life is just ashes
and here it is number 95 as of stalker
Street mariopol an image captured
shortly after it was hit on the 15th of
March
Yes actually it's a ghost City because
we can you you go get out into the
street and you can see the skeletons
black black and skeletons of nine-story
buildings because they were burnt down
and you we don't even know how many
people were killed inside the hospitals
were hit as well and and and the school
that you taught in your English teachers
both of you the school that you taught
in that too has been destroyed yes our
school was built in 1936
and it survived German occupation you
know yeah it didn't survive this no
it's somewhere here on a map they point
out School number 40 Drone footage taken
in the last week shows what's left of it
the destruction here is breathtaking
imagine living it
we showed the sound sound of the plane
and then horrible boom and the whole
building shaking we could see that half
of the building was burned down or was
just destroyed we could hear people
crying it was horrible and the constant
flow of people who were trying to come
to the hospital to get some shelter
because they were scared they brought
children they were wounded they were
brought without legs wounded children
killed children it was horrible
we are only just beginning to discover
what happened and what is still
happening in mariopol the mayor says
more than 21
000 people have been killed here since
the Russian invasion
they call themselves The liberators they
come and they say we have liberated you
from what they have liberated us from
our life they have liberated us from our
apartments from our money from jobs from
our jobs from our relatives because a
lot of people were killed so what have
you liberated us from we had a good life
for 50 58 years you lived one life and
and then
at the end of March
you started Living different life you
know and you can't imagine how it could
happen
in a peaceful City
[Music]
and so it is moments like this that must
raise spirits
reunions with old friends from a city
now gone
knock Stone Sky News in Ukraine